guys are incredibly busy at Agbo and I
wanted to know what is what is coming up
for you guys there that you're excited
about or sort of you know what can you
tease fans of yours and Anthony well we
have obviously of cherry coming up next
that'll be the next thing to release but
we have a project we're really excited
about with the Obamas called exit West
which is based on a tremendous book a
beautifully written novel
heart-wrenching and that's another
project that we have a Netflix with them
we're really looking forward to that
we've got a sports documentary that
we're doing with Tom Brady for IMAX
obviously behind DB depending on you
know what happens with the forthcoming
NFL season but you know we love Tom and
admire him and think what he's doing at
the AG's at it's exceptional and and
historic what else are we working on
we've got a lot of projects sorry to
tease but a lot of big IP projects that
we're working on very secretly and very
quietly so we have something we're
working on with Marcus McFeely and have
been working on for about the past eight
months that'll be the next big I pee
thing that we do I definitely have to do
a follow-up on exit west because I
believe it was a website called Collider
that actually wrote that story negatives
and that story that is correct yes so I
have to do a follow up and say is R is
still believe in that movie yes and is
it something that you envision assuming
we get past this we get past the virus
is that something that you guys have a
script on that you guys are that it's
relatively it could get in front of
camera soon it could definitely get in
front of camera soon the question is
obviously one and that's a question
everyone in the industry is asking at
the moment you know sets are crowded
there's a lot of people on set certainly
it you know a high risk for a breakout
amongst
Kru and so the questions are how we how
do we protect each other in ourselves